im bayrischen plattling ist am
donnerstagabend eine 20 jährige frau ums
leben gekommen
sie wurde von ihrem lebensgefährten auf
einem supermarktparkplatz mit mehreren
messerstichen getötet
augenzeugen beobachteten die tat konnten
aber nicht mehr rechtzeitig eingreifen
sie riefen die polizei die den 28
jährigen afghanen noch vor ort
festnehmen und zur kriminalpolizei nach
deggendorf brachte dort soll er heute
dem haftrichter vorgeführt werden
das gemeinsame kind der beiden soll bei
der tat dabei gewesen sein
blieb aber unverletzt der säugling ist
nach bild informationen erst acht monate
alt und wurde dem jugendamt übergeben
einzelheiten zum tathergang und den
hintergründen sind aktuell noch nicht
bekannt die kriminalpolizei hat die
ermittlungen übernommen